there's a view around that the most
romantic thing you can tell someone else
is I don't want to change a thing about
you I love you exactly as you are
according to a prevalent romantic
philosophy love is definitely not meant
to be about trying to alter another
person but a blanket refusal to listen
to any idea of change at our lovers
hands would only make sense if we were
in fact already more or less perfect and
yet the more time two people spend
around each other the more they're
naturally going to spot things that are
a little less than ideal it might be
something quite small their way of
chewing perhaps for something larger
their attitude to their career or family
many other people might have spotted
these problems before if they never said
anything it's not because they're nicer
just far less concerned but our lovers
can and have to be bothered
it's the mixed privilege of the job
however because the concept of Education
in love has such low status things tend
to go terribly wrong when there's a
lesson to impart from a lack of
confidence in the legitimacy of their
task the lover with something to teach
maybe neither calm nor prepared
furthermore because so much is at stake
a fear of not being listened to over
something vital can quickly explode into
really
as for the one who has something to
learn our culture immediately makes them
feel that feedback is by nature
unromantic and illegitimate they can
feel got at picked on and humiliated and
so may fall back on that comforting yet
nonsensical line you wouldn't criticize
me if you loved me in love with too
often terrible educators and students
yet in truth were also imperfect we've
got to teach and learn good criticism is
the salvation not the end of love a
thought about love is about tolerating
and accepting frailties but some of it
is also about offering the sort of
feedback that no one else gives a damn
enough to give us love should be not
about cherishing everything but about
seeing the full potential in one another
and therefore about trusting in one
another enough to listen to challenging
information good love means two people
on a rotating basis knowing how to take
on the roles both of really kind teacher
and deeply open-minded under ffensive
student did you know that the school of
life is actually a place ten places in
fact campuses all over the world from
Melbourne to London Taipei to Istanbul
with classes and books and lots more
please click on the link below to
explore more